this is the most incredible place I know
I love writing poems about the beautiful
planet it got me to the funnel I've been
Got Talent this is the moment when the
world met Anisha
four yeses
but the Earth has a problem
changing and it's making me sad
we need a solution
but the grown-ups are strugging with
difficult choices
in this show there are six of us from
six different nations who's up towards
kids it's a razor of voices
this is six ways to save our planet
[Music]
this place is mysterious planet Earth is
under threat from the climate crisis so
I'm on a mission to find out what we can
do to save our planet
helping me out I have five friends
around the world we're gonna start in
Kenya in Africa
[Music]
I have planted over 1 million trees
across Africa and just near my home in
the city of Nairobi Kenya with
permission of course
here I organize events to get lots of
people to buy seeds and plant trees
they help soak up climate changing gases
like carbon dioxide produced by cars and
power stations
when the world leaders announced the
next climate change Summit cop 27 was to
be held in Africa in Egypt I was glad
because they need to listen up
[Music]
this is what it's like in East and
Northern Kenya
just a few hours drive from my city
it used to be green and healthy land
producing food for those who lived there
but look at it now
the land is dry
the crops are failing
people are starving here
[Music]
Kenya is experiencing its worst job in
40 years
more than 7 million people in the north
and east are without food or access to
water
Millions more in neighboring countries
Africa is among the smallest producers
of carbon dioxide
yet it is becoming the biggest victim of
climate change
[Music]
[Music]
I'm heading to West Kenya where there is
also a draft but here there is hope
just a few years ago parts of this
region had become so dry it had been
declared a semi-desert but now look at
it when Farmers here saw how climate
change was destroying their fertile land
they took action before it was too late
I discovered that farmers in the west
have avoided a famine they are learning
about a new way to grow crops and it
evolved my favorite weapon to be climate
change
please
[Music]
this one maze
Charities are teaching young Farmers
like Naman that trees not only save dry
and damaged soil but also protect their
crops from drought I can show you have
some purpose over there yes these ones
fruits you can eat either you like you
can sell but before Naman could grow his
cross he needed trees lots of them the
issue is they had all been chopped down
traditionally Farmers destroy forests to
create Fields so where did all these
trees come from
it was discovered that if a stump of a
tree had sheets like this you could
bring the tree and the soil back to life
but once the trees are established the
roots draw up water buried deep
underground and hold rain water around
its roots
Cherry Roots also attract food for the
crops minerals and organic material
known as nutrients
and the cheese act like a canopy
protecting the crops from the wind and
the burning Sun
Naman learned about this method of
farming at school when he was 12. he
gave it a go with no income Naman needed
to do something to save the family
when you got your first ever cup I feel
excited because the demand of products
was very high
three years on Naman and his family are
producing enough crops to feed
themselves and others and he is passing
on his knowledge to the next generation
of young farmers
[Music]
Charities have trained more than a
hundred thousand young Farmers had to
bring their Farms back to life in other
parts of Africa the land is lost it is
too late but here there is a real hope
you know what Nisha I want Africa to
help others what I found here is answers
not problems
sanctuary and so what can we do here in
the UK to make sure our food what we're
eating isn't harming the planet
well one idea is to grow food in your
garden like this pear tree
and my mum and dad have made me a
greenhouse let's go and look at it
whoa this thing is very Lush and I think
I found a cucumber there he is he hasn't
been plopped off yet I know a lot of
people don't have Garden plate hours but
you can even grow stuff in a window box
like strawberries baby carrots or even
salads
one of the reasons our climate is
changing is unlike my pears most of our
food has been transported from all over
the globe think of all the ships all the
lorries bringing our food into our
supermarkets they use fossil fuels like
diesels that is really bad for the
environment
to show you what I mean I'm gonna do a
little experiment down here we have a
load of things that my mum and dad have
bought from the local supermarkets and
over here we have a map of the world so
where everything comes from so these
green beans are from Kenya okay let's
leave it there let's get a pin and let's
put it right in Kenya so what do we have
next
we got kiwis from New Zealand that's
really far away
apples
from Italy asparagus is yes from Peru
that's where parenting lives and
tomatoes from Morocco that is so weird
because we already have tomatoes in my
back Garden
so how many miles have all this fruit
and veg traveled to get to my house
well I've been doing some Sons on my
dad's calculator and guess what
[Music]
2590 miles
that's about the same distance as
traveling around the world
four times wow there's got to be a
better way to get off it right well
maybe we just need to build a greenhouse
like mine but make it humongously huge a
bit like
this one
this is one of the biggest greenhouses
in the UK just outside Norwich it's the
same size as 26 football pitches I've
never seen anything like this before in
my life
the man who owns this place is called
Chris and I really want to ask him some
questions
how can a John Greenhouse like this help
to save the planet because by growing
like this we can save 60 of carbon
emissions by not importing food from
other places
where are there different ways why this
place is eco-friendly well what we do we
Harvest every drop of rain water to feed
the plants and because of this we hardly
use any pesticides and then there's one
other big secret that you have to go
down the road to see that that sounds
very mysterious
huh why have I been brought to the local
social work
when you've lost your toilet at home
when you have a shower the waste water
ends up at a place like this it's a
little bit stinky but I don't know what
this is about with tomatoes and
cucumbers
so those crops in our glass house they
require heat to grow and the amazing
thing is that when we have treated water
on this site we take the heat from that
treated water and send that to The Glass
House did you say the heat from where we
is used to grow salad that's an amazing
fact so when you flush the toilet it's
got heat in there and we use that heat
for those crops to grow that is amazing
so the heating system in the greenhouse
is using hot water though the other ones
have been wasted it's basically a way of
growing healthy food that isn't causing
as much damage to our planet
if every country does this it will make
a huge difference
[Music]
most of us these days live in towns and
cities and very often that means there's
loads of pollution from the traffic but
what if we can change all that well the
next idea to save the planet all comes
from a friend of mine in Colombia you're
gonna love this
foreign
[Music]
country Colombia this is Bogota
there is so much traffic here the city
is very overcrowded
so it's no wonder that Bogota is best
known for being one of the most polluted
cities on Earth
I know what's a title
this is a problem here's the issue oil
is a fossil fuel we get from deep
underground it sees to make petrol and
diesel for transport when that expanded
in an engine it releases gases to the
exhaust pipe into the atmosphere those
gases chop the Earth's heat causing
global warming which leads to climate
change we're all beginning to experience
[Music]
pollution can make really ill it can
damage our lungs when we breathe it in
right foreign
is so bad here that there are monitoring
instruments all over the city collecting
data to see how much pollution there is
in the air
[Music]
this website gives live updates
114 is very warring because it is a very
high level of pollution where I am
but the biggest victim of this pollution
is planet Earth
[Applause]
this is my cousin Francisco
we got so angry about pollution we set
up a campaign group and Stage protests
to demand the government to do more
in 2021 some of us traveled Glasgow for
cop 26. the last meeting of world
leaders to discuss climate change and we
staged a protest with Greta turnberg
just giving ourselves a voice to be
heard can help save our planet
San Francisco and our government is
listening now
in the last few years the authorities
have spent hundreds of millions of
pounds making Transportation the city
cleaner
and we got to say too the authorities
asked residents for their ideas at
meetings and surveys
[Music]
the outer cable Castle takes us across
the city
we can now travel seven miles without
the need to drive or get a bus
we are so clean the buses Bogota now has
the second largest feat of electric
buses in the world
1485 of them
and we now have the longest network of
safety Lanes in Latin America
[Music]
I am very happy because yes I think
we've made progress yes I think there is
a better future so hopefully the
government will support the city to be a
Greener City and that helps the
environment back to you nishwa
thank you Sarah I wish we had cable cars
in my town it would be so cool
but what can we do to make sure we're
not polluting the planet and we're
traveling around the UK
well here's one idea if you don't
already have a bike why don't you learn
how to ride one there are lots of
schemes for us to learn how to ride
cycle safely and every time you ride on
one instead of going on your mum's or
Dad's car that can help to stop climate
change
one of the biggest problems in our
cities is that there isn't much space
for the natural world but it doesn't
have to be that way the next big idea to
save the planet comes from Sadie in
Singapore
[Music]
welcome to one of the smallest countries
in the world
this is my home and even though I'm just
an ordinary kid I'm kind of protective
about it
the way I see it there's nowhere else
like this on Earth
its nickname is the city in a garden and
it's easy to see why
but all this Greenery isn't just to look
pretty it's also doing a really
important job
Singapore is one of the hottest places
on the planet so for many years now the
city authorities have been looking for
innovative ways to cool things down
and they've discovered something quite
incredible that the rest of the world
can learn from as our planet heats up
it's not rocket science Singapore's
secret is actually quite simple okay are
you ready here we go
yup simply by planting trees this city
has lowered the air temperature by up to
2 degrees Celsius the trees provide
shade and release cooling water vapor
into the air from their leaves
[Music]
this is a major tourist attraction
called Gardens by the bay where you can
take a walk above a canopy of trees
you'll also find vegetation on lots of
Singapore's buildings including this
eco-friendly Hotel
at the airport where they've got their
own rainforest waterfall
I love it here it's like a high-tech
Tropical Paradise
but even though Singapore has made a
good start with more than half of our
land now covered with trees we know
we've got to do more to tackle climate
change so our government has drawn up
what it calls the green plant so what
will the green plan mean for us well the
green plan is actually trying to turn
Singapore into a city in nature and that
means putting in so many parks and green
spaces such that nobody living in
Singapore is more than 10 minutes walk
away from a place like this you look at
the bird's eye view of Singapore you
will see a city very busy full of people
but at the same time it's all green it
looks like a jungle and that's what we
aim to do and what are the advantages of
creating more green spaces Greenery and
nature plants they capture carbon it
cools the planet and the green spaces
also provide living spaces for lots of
interesting animals but what about all
the buildings in Singapore there's a lot
of concrete right there is a lot of
concrete but what Singapore does very
well and is trying to improve on is
putting plants on buildings many of
these buildings houses and hotels have
vertical Greenery it's not easy to do
but we have tried our very best and I
think we have done very well in doing so
that all sounds really sensible but
there is a problem Singapore still uses
a lot of air conditioning units can you
see them up there they're pretty ugly to
be honest and they use up loads of
energy the way they work is by pumping
hot air out of buildings that people
work and live in it's not very
eco-friendly
so here's another idea that Singapore is
trying out the city's Engineers say that
down there is one of the largest systems
of its kind in the whole world an
underground network of pipes sending
chilled water through an entire District
the pipes travel through all buildings
helping to cool down the air inside
it will cut down the amount of energy we
use by more than 40 percent as well as
reducing carbon emissions
you can probably tell I'm really quite
proud of my country and everything we're
doing to tackle climate change and at
night the man-made super trees are lit
up in a spectacular display powered by
solar energy
it's like a Beacon of Hope for the
future of our planet right that's pretty
cool
[Music]
thank you so much I wonder what we can
do here in the UK to change our concrete
jungles into nature Reserves
well just like in Singapore some of our
towns and cities have started to build
living walls with plants on them to
Circle harmful gases like carbon dioxide
okay it's time to have our next idea to
save the planet and this one's actually
quite simple instead of using fossil
fuels to create electricity let's try
and use something Greener and cleaner
let's go to Australia
welcome to my home Sydney Australia just
like you and Nisha I love everything
about our planet especially the
incredible marine life we share it with
about
whenever I go for a surf dive or even a
swim and make sure to look out for
rubbish in case it hurts any marine life
we're pretty good here in Australia but
there are other things we need to work
on
[Music]
my country is the world's second biggest
producer of coal we dig it up and
explore it overseas it's mainly used by
power stations that burn cold heat water
creating steam that power turbines which
produces electricity
Carl is a fossil fuel releasing the very
gases into the atmosphere that lead to
climate change
despite pressure to stop producing coal
Australia refuses but things are
changing
I'm about to take a flight to examine
something so huge that we have to use a
helicopter to see all of it
we're taking off really close to where
we need to go to use the minimum amount
of fuel what we're about to see is
awesome
this is the country's largest Hall of
firm producing huge amounts of
electricity generated by the sun's
powerful rays
I'm flying over Darlington Point solar
farm
here they're oversee nearly 1 million
solar panels
[Music]
about 110 000 homes every single year a
hundred and ten thousand homes is about
the same as the city the size of
Plymouth in the UK this produces no
carbon dioxide at all it's a state of
the art facility that you know is really
leading the way in terms of innovation
for what we can do all across the planet
and solar energy is about to get bigger
in Australia a lot bigger construction
is about to begin on the world's largest
solar farm with up to 28 million solar
panels the energy it creates will be
sold and exported to Singapore using a
giant cable this is the future exporting
green energy to countries that don't
have the land for solar Farms like
Australia does
foreign
[Music]
how advanced our technology is
I feel really hopeful towards our future
and how far this technology can go
now I know that people are really
putting in the work and trying to make
this world a better place for
generations and generations to come
[Music]
I mean we have quite a lot of uniforms
in the UK too this one isn't so far away
from my house and this one has been
built on an old RAF base in Norfolk next
we're heading to the United States of
America to hear about an idea what may
totally change the world it may sound a
bit weird but I'm gonna let my friend
Lila tell you more
you might recognize this place from the
Spider-Man movies it's probably the most
famous city in the world welcome to my
home New York
unfortunately New York's got a problem a
really big problem as our planet's
climate changes the ice caps are melting
and there are more and more storms
and because New York is surrounded by
water it means that flooding is becoming
more and more common just take a look at
this this is not a disaster movie it's
real life Hurricane Sandy in 2012 and
hurricane Ida in 2021 caused immense
damage many people lost their lives
for my family it was a really scary time
I remember one night we were watching TV
and we just heard this gushing noise
from downstairs we went down and there
was like a waterfall pouring through my
window I think at one point the water
was up to like here
some New York residents are now asking
themselves how much longer they can go
on living here and the sea level
continues to rise
one possible solution is to try and hold
back the waves with the sea wall and
that's exactly what they're doing here
the city is spending billions of pounds
on flood defenses
so here's the thing flood defenses are
great but some people think they're just
a sticking plaster and eventually a bit
like with my sand castle the rising sea
levels will do their damage
so do we need a more radical solution to
save our coastal cities and ultimately
to save Humanity
well how about this an incredible vision
of the future like something out of a
movie
welcome to the world's first floating
city
so this is just a computer-generated
animation showing what it might look
like but believe it or not a city like
this could soon become a reality I'm
meeting the chief engineer from a
company called oceanx which is hoping to
build the world's first floating city in
South Korea the advantage of food in
seeding is we can move up and down with
the ways and with the tides and the FED
it is floating is also helpful because
it will accommodate the sea water level
rising so is this an exception that we
just can't beat climate change we're
gonna have to live with it I believe
what we're doing right now here is
trying to find the solutions to a
problem that is actually becoming real
there are a lot of Nations right now
where their population has been
displaced they becoming climate refugees
and so if it's going to be Solutions and
this is one of the solution and we're
we're going to pursue with them
so maybe we're gonna need a new New York
a city that floats like a boat how crazy
is that
[Music]
I'd say it's very crazy but also quite
cool
so that's it the six ways to save the
planet number one
crops that can cope with drought
conditions number two improving public
transports to reduce pollution from cars
and lorries
number three bringing nature into our
cities to cool the temperature and soak
up the carbon number four using more
renewable energy like solar power
number five
producing our Foods much closer to home
like in these giant greenhouses
and number six find out new ideas like
floating cities to help us live on the
ocean
what's clear is if we really want to
save our planet it's up to us
we all have to play our part no matter
how old we are or where we live we can
do this guys but we got to make changes
now